me de sauver quelques arbres mais le
traitement nous ré fait que prolonger
l'agonie à grands frais et surprenant à
cet hiver de votre que les autres partis
à bruxelles mais c'est bien parti pour
pour boiser innocence on dirait que ils
savent ce qu'ils font le reboisement va
bon train et on prend garde à protéger
les jeunes pousses des chevreuils est
bloqué avec des toiles une autre espèce
envahissante le nerprun qui pourrait
prendre tout le terrain et ont fait un
beau travail
c'est c'est juste que le vin l'on enlève
tous frères fixé c'est tout mais je suis
très satisfait du travail accompli
depuis 2016 on ne replanter huit mille
arbres il ya plusieurs milliers qui s'en
viennent aussi au cours des trois
prochaines années
longueuil n'est toutefois pas encore et
vente auriez les freine dans les grands
parcs comme le boisé du tremblay où le
parc michel chartrand dans ces milieux
protégés intervenir n'est pas
nécessairement la meilleure solution
l'opération de remplacement des frênes
est loin d'être terminée à longueuil
cet hiver on compte en abad plus de 5000
mais à la fin la ville espère avoir
planté autant d'arbres qu'elle en a
abattu
ici une chaîne marsolais radio canada
longueuil
on vient d'assister au mexique à l'une
des batailles les plus violentes de ces
dernières années les membres d'un cartel
s'en sont pris hier on policiers et
militaires qui venaient arrêter l'une
des figures de lempire de la drogue
le fils